servus sg zh und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video wir sind heute in
unserem garten das heißt markt auf den
nippel scharfsinnig begrüßt über den
schatten main äppel romantisch am start
stopp und hinter der kamera ist und ihr
seht euch den ersten lucentis dass wir
in badehosen sind wo und zweitens dass
hier zwei stühle stehen
naja wir spieler mich heute dass er holt
das ist wie das klassische roulette mit
der pistole
da machen wir eine patrone in den
revolver rein dreht die trommel und dann
das ist nett das heißt von diesen zehn
eiern sind acht gekocht und zwei nicht
gekocht was sie machen werden ist sie
werden jeweils mit dem man schon die
eier herausnehmen und mit schmackes
gegen die stirn
die gekochten sind natürlich
ungefährlich die cracks nur an aber die
ungekochten werden explodieren und eine
andere erklärung geben explodieren
und wir müssen das erstmal aus wer gegen
wen antritt ich natürlich sowieso
weismain channels aber max und luqmon
beide nicht so wirklich woche dabei zu
sein einmal muss er machen konnte
stellen jetzt fest wir einmal nämlich
einmal einmal machen und wenn du unten
stehst dann halt noch mal also ich bin
quasi das 1 schere stein papier würde
ich doch berichten die gleichen schritte
im kopf her da film ich doch wieder
machen wir ja schlechter
also es gibt es gibt acht gekochten sie
ungefährlich und zwei und gekochte die
übung explodiert
und wir nehmen ihn mit dem handschuh
damit wir nicht feststellen können
welche gekommen
schon gegen ihren privaten verkehrs
dachte okay du hast noch mal durch
menschen befürchten nehmen
wie soll man so ja so viel vorsicht
ich habe meinen ja das war wohl
übertrieben hat es gibt kein richtiger
nerven jetzt sind es fast durch den kopf
stellen wir noch zwei eier drin und das
sind beides jugend wollen dann wissen
wir wenn wir noch zeit übrig haben wir
auf wurde natürlich wenn beide foul er
schon gezogen worden
hey leute freut sich gefragt haben was
dann auch mit neuen interessieren der
massenandrang mit einem rezept von aus
mutter genau
richtig sch
wie base ist halt echt so richtiger
nervenkitzel obwohl quasi nur eier sind
solar aber das ist einfach saugeil ich
so eine clique ist ihm das nicht eklig
das habe ich auch gerade das gekauft
mich durch das frisch wir haben noch
sieben eier drin und ich fragte so ab
dass max schön oder der kamera die
herren eine frisch geduscht und wie
kommen wir gerade kommt
ok kannst also ich spüre es schon
richtig hin jetzt voll in die hose geht
das vor allem die einzige kurze wurde
liegt gerade mit haben werke
ich habe nicht so viel nicht so fest wie
eben aber das wird schon wieder hell
sind und dann nur diese eier dann ein
das sind zwei ungekochten 50
hätten sie
die schmerzen
jetzt nur noch eines ist jetzt gekommen
unser land jetzt die schwester die
brüder aus
das war was grössten schweizer
ausgemacht wie kam das
vielleicht hat mir fällt ein max für
fielmann nach auch ob da wirklich zwar
nicht gekocht sind ja wir sind zwar
nicht gekocht bis wirklich sehr delikat
dass so eine komische appelle sind also
immer gibt ich hab das ja alter die
chance ist jetzt ein buch steht nicht
fifty fifty fifty fifty chance dass du
einzelne fresse kriegt und danach sechs
und 60 prozentige chance dass ein ja
oder 333 haben am super habe zwei punkte
es ist halt wirklich zwei nicht gekommen
in der wärme deswegen habe den
handschlag
der handschuh etwas machen jetzt damit
habe ich so eine steuer in die hand
drücken und sagen komm junge ja das hab
ich bis jetzt 33 prozentige chance
bekommen zu werden
dass du ich brauche was aber macht die
augen zu das ja gar in die eier
abgeführt du kannst glück haben und
deswegen hat die augen dass die ganze
zeit geschlossen
nehmen wir ein ei und dann richtig
runter getroffen heute wir müssen es
wieder schnell wenden wir haben zwei
eier übrig beide nicht gekochten eier
wurden verballert 1 hat mich erwischt
eins los wenn ich das gefallen hat dann
weiter bis zum nächsten mal